life freedom  I will always have Hope and Faith in the  people of Iran and especially in the  women of Iran the feminist movement is  not born yesterday or three weeks ago  the feminist movement is over 100 years  old and I am convinced that history will  change either with force or with cutting  of our hairs  I mean the Iranian mullah regime has  never cared about anything but their own  interests and creating legitimacy for  their own existence benefiting from the  Iran from the country and I am convinced  that one day the fall will come and  there will be a free Democratic Iran  that is open and welcoming and including  for every Iranian citizen